وقعت كالصاعقه على الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ظننا بان اوكرانيا ستخسر حليفا
قويا وروسيا ستخسر عدوا شرسا
لكن شيئا لم يتغير الحرب ذكرت بريطانيا في
اوروبا وفعلت سياسه خارجيه متميزه عن
اوروبا بعد
ومخالفه لنهج برلين وباريس الحديد
المملكه المتحده تلعب دورها التقليدي مره
اخرى عندما يكون هناك انقسام وعندما يكون
هناك استقطاب في قناتنا دائما ما تكون
المملكه المتحده بقوتها كعضو دائم في مجلس
الامن وواحده من افضل الجيوش العسكريه في
قاراتنا لتقديم تضحيه الاقتصاديه اللازمه
لاظهار هذه القياده
ولا صوت يعلو فوق صوت المعركه خلافات
الاحزاب البريطانيه وضعت جانبا والجميع
انتهج سياسه متشدده تجاه الكرملين
او برج دونس حزب المحافظين او العمال
وجهان لعمله واحده فمهما تغيرت الوجوه في
دون ستريت او تحت قبه البرلمان الدعم
العسكري والانساني لاوكرانيا لا يتغير
ان دعم المملكه المتحده للشعب الاوكراني
موحد وفي حال اجراء انتخاباتنا العام
المقبل وتغيير الحكومه فان موقف المملكه
المتحده بشان اوكرانيا سيظل على حاله
يهبط الجنيه الاسترليني ام يرتفع تسقط
حكومه او تنتخب جديده تختلف الاحزاب
المعارضه مع الحكومه او تهادن لا فرق
سياسه بريطانيا ثابته في هذه الحمله
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا روسيا تحارب
على القاره الاوروبيه ومهما كانت عباء
الحرب على الحياه اليوميه للبريطانيين
لندن قررت مواجهه موسكو في اوكرانيا مصطفى
زاروه العربيه لندن